the search continues tonight for the men
police say are responsible for shooting
and killing two people on the west side
of the valley the shooting happened
Friday night on Cindy Sue Street that's
near Rancho and Vegas Drive the family
of one of the victims spoke to Victoria
Saha they tell her they want answers as
to why the man and woman were targeted
a memorial now sits at the crime scene
after 19-year-old Samir Smith and 24
year old Diana Marie Diaz were killed in
this apartment Friday night Smith lived
just two doors down from here he was
with Diaz in her apartment when the two
were gunned down we always stuck close
together Samir Smith's mom and older
brother are still trying to figure out
why Smith a young man who kept to
himself and never got in trouble became
the victim of gun violence I moved out
here from Chicago to give kids away from
shootings and
foreign
Smith and his neighbor Deanna Diaz were
inside her apartment when two men
knocked on the door Diaz answered but
Smith and the two men started arguing
that's when both were shot I just peeked
my head out and uh
I screamed out samir's name to see if he
would respond to me and uh
he didn't Smith's brother nadir heard
the shots from two doors down and ran
over I didn't see any type of like pain
in his face or anything it's just I
think it's him seeing me kind of like
put him at peace a bit families say
Smith and Diaz were very close and spent
a lot of time together but believe he
was at the wrong place at the wrong time
he didn't have a police record
so I had to go and identify him on
Tuesday Morning Diaz's distraught family
was seen moving her things out of her
apartment off camera her cousin who
witnessed the shooting tells me one of
the suspects had a ski mask on in the
meantime Smith's mom has a message for
the men who took her son's life when you
get caught your family's gonna be hurt
too your family your mom is gonna hurt
too Smith's mom says that since her son
was always a giver she has chosen to
donate his body to science Metro Police
have not made any arrest in this case
and if you have any information about
the suspects you were asked to call
crime stopper hours that number is
702-385-5555 reporting from the west
side of the valley Victoria Saha live
local now